you're not gonna [ __ ] over in that
door what if it's ask you what if it
kills both of us
[Music]
[Applause]
this girl my high school at this massive
house and it was like overlooking the
valley and she'd always throw parties my
ex was there with his friends him and I
actually broke up literally the day
party he was a star quarterback of our
high school got a lot of attention
there's pictures of him in restaurants
and bars
everyone wanted him the girls guys it
was like I was dating some celebrities
closeted the whole relationship I wanted
to be out I wanted to experience PDA
ended up telling one of my friends cuz I
was tired of keeping everything a secret
I guess it was just too juicy of
information hold in because literally
everyone found out the next day he was
like I'm accorded by people can't know
me it's being like that he wanted to
date other people and women because you
know the reputation thing we just came
to the conclusion that we should just
break up I originally had this party I
was supposed to lose my virginity to my
ex we planned it we talked about it
everything was leading up to that night
basically this guy who happens to be my
ex's best friend he was also like a
closeted straight football player not
everyone you know knew and loved he
comes up to me and we're like talking
and yeah I'm just hanging out you know I
don't want to get to know you better I
didn't go to him thinking oh I'm gonna
go try to hook up with him because he's
my ex's best friend but it just made it
a plus he picks me up we're in the car
we're parked on this little dugout way
up in the mountains
it's pitch black outside we made out for
like maybe two minutes and then she was
just like oh we should go in the back we
put all the seats down I had never had
anything go your you know my ass he puts
on a condom and he like just kind of
like rams it in me like no like warning
note for plate I literally heard like
like a popping sound if I remember
correctly I'm pretty sure the first
thing I said was I think you just tore
my
after that moment it felt like a lot
better
well we're [ __ ] I heard like a tap it
sounded like someone threw a rock at the
car I'm like okay like what is that
noise this is like it's probably like a
coyote or something like who cares and
then we start emailing scratching it
would like move the car kind of like
wait what the [ __ ] like he's scratching
my [ __ ] car and he wanted to open the
door I remember we got in like this huge
fight about like him opening door
because I was like wait you're not gonna
[ __ ] move in that door like what if
it's a mountain lion like what if it
attacks you like what if it kills both
of us and he's like no I'm just a
mountain lion I'm gonna [ __ ] like
kill that [ __ ] I'm kind of hitting the
car and like scratching and I think I
started to like cry BAM oh and he was
like okay like I should drive uh-huh I
mean I barely remember saying bye and
that's how brief it was I told you know
one person again and kind of like the
same snowball of talking like just got
around like he was really hurt
I haven't seen my accents I was
disappointed in myself if you're like
you know young and you're out and you're
proud you should be with someone who's
like that
I felt degraded because like I felt like
I wasn't really worth coming out for
like I wasn't good enough for him to
brag about them like just tell everyone
but I didn't know that at the time I
didn't feel that I didn't feel better so
I would just say like even if you feel
like you're waiting a long time like
just wait for like the right person
[Music]